so i want you to think about the top 10
bad decisions you made in your life
which one of those decisions were you
more happy when you made that decision
or were you more angry when you made
that decision meaning for example you're
partying you're going things are going
great you're so happy guy offers you
drugs you do it you get addicted you
lose three years of your life
hypothetically or you're so angry at
somebody you end up making a dumb
decision with a relationship and it
costs you one of your best friends and x
a relationship with a relative
which of those two
feelings emotions produce worse
decisions for you so i'm sharing this
with you not only from the standpoint of
an individual as well as as a leader so
any time like for myself
when we're kids you know when we go to
our parents or to our dad for money
you're like oh that looks happy he's in
a good mood hey dad can i get a hundred
dollars you know i want to go out there
and do this yeah son here's a hundred
dollars and then later on turn like why
did i get my son a hundred dollars but
the kid capitalized because that was in
good mood that's what i'm talking about
or you're angry like i can't believe
this is what happened and you go through
that process anytime you're trying to do
this as an individual or a leader the
best place for my experience to be when
making a decision is to be here as
closely to independent and middle as
possible too angry you make decisions
you typically burn something and you're
going to overreact to it too happy
you're going to make decisions you're
probably going to be too optimistic
thinking everything is going to work out
maybe it's a good idea to use one phrase
before you make that decision and you
know what that simple phrase is
let me think about it let me get back to
you let me simmer on this give me a day
so whether it's happy or extremely angry
take a few hours take a few minutes take
maybe a day to make the decision
probably a day later you're going to
make the better decision than in that
moment when you're angry or in that
moment when you're happy if you got
value from this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel if you
haven't seen the video i made how to
make tough decisions click over here to
watch that video take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]